who would be who would be
the anthony fauci of you know climate
change who would that voice people well
it depends on you again it's not nih
it's not going to be cdc who's that
person going to be who's leading the
paris climate accord well you have john
kerry and uh gina mccarthy are in the
biden administration so john kerry is
the sort of the climate the
international climate envoy and then you
have gina mccarthy who's like the
domestic one and wasn't kerry also the
head of the iran nuclear deal
yeah he was yes so he's doing climate
and nuclear and john kerry he's the
perfect spokesman for this but john
kerry you know he's he comes off he
doesn't do the cause any good for the
climate movement but
it comes and i have a whole chapter in
my new book on this whole idea of
credentialed scientists
in the the whole process and essentially
what they do is they're using science as
a lobbying tool and i think it was
thomas soule whose famous quote was you
know science government science or they
bring in the science when to support
decisions already made by bureaucrats
essentially or by government and that's
what they do it's very easy to find
any position you want when it comes to
science like that
and you line up in administration give
you a case in point biden has an epa
advisory board that was there they
didn't like any of the trump appointees
i think they're getting rid of like 50
plus of these scientists
because they wouldn't agree with biden's
view on climate and environment so once
they get rid of them within a year when
peyton proposes a new environmental
protection agency climate rule they can
credibly say there wasn't any dissent
and i knew 100 of our scientists all
agreed with it well if you'd been paying
attention a year ago they just
eliminated a third of the scientists
because they knew they wouldn't agree
they just removed them from the board
this is how they create science
consensus you have these national
academy of science the american
meteorological the american geophysical
union
look at this they came out with a
statement in support of al gore in the
u.n tens of thousands of scientists
endorsed the view that climate is
causing harm oh really it was a
governing board of two dozen or so
elected officials voted without direct
vote or input of the of the members that
tens of thousands of members of these
groups in the case of american
meteorological society there were
studies that up to 75 at one point were
skeptical of man-made climate change at
least 50 but it didn't matter because
the two dozen governing board members
steeped in politics lobbying
and government connections voted that we
agree with the un al gore view and so
that whole organization there's another
one of the consensus can i use thousands
of scientists be wrong
that was the whole point of the way it's
just about stopping debate stopping
stuff so that we have to accept the
premise and then we have to be accept
their forced rushed solution because we
don't have time to act we're running out
of time so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
[Music]